retinoids are the gold standard skincare
ingredients they are the next essential
product right after sunscreen because
they can help you with so many skin
issues and there's scientific evidence
to back them up but it's really tricky
to work out which one you should use and
it really doesn't help that there's so
much incorrect info out there but if you
find the right one it can make such a
huge difference to your skin my PhD is
in Medicinal Chemistry and I'm a
qualified cosmetic chemist so seeing all
these myths and traps that people fall
for when it comes to R oids that
physically hurts me so in this video I'm
going to break down drug versus cosmetic
retinoids their pros and cons why drugs
are a bit overrated Cosmetics are really
underrated and compound of retinoids are
super overrated which one you should use
and I'm going to bust a whole bunch of
myths along the way if you don't already
know retinoids are skincare ingredients
that work like vitamin A they work by
attaching to retinoid receptors in your
skin basically retinoids are like keys
that fit into locks which are the
receptors and when that happens they
will trigger an effect or rather they
trigger a whole bunch of effects which
is why rids are so great in skincare but
also why they burn your freaking face
off but we will get to that in a bit if
you're looking into skincare you
probably have some sort of goal in mind
and retinoids will probably help you
towards that goal if you have acne then
retinoids can stop pores from clogging
up and turning into pimples if you want
to even out pigment then Rino can help
normalize that pigment production
process if you want less wrinkles
smoothed out scars and pores then renoid
will increase collagen that's a protein
that's inside your dermis that makes it
like a thicker mattress but not all
retinoids work the same and not all
products with the same retinoid will
work the same either some retinoids are
drugs and for these you will generally
need a scrp but adapalene is available
over the counter sometimes cosmetic
retinoids like retinol are in regular
skincare products my PhD was mostly
Medicinal Chemistry and I studied
pharmacology and undergrads so when I
first started getting into skincare it
just seemed like why would anyone use
Cosmetics when you could just use the
drugs lots of doctors and scientists
think this way and that's because most
scientists and doctors don't get taught
much about cosmetics and honestly not
that much about drugs either or at least
the finer details but there are some
really well-known benefits of drugs
first off drug ingredients have
demonstrated efficacy and that means
they've gone through an approval process
it is a bit like hazing except for
molecules there are studies done using
these on lots of people and then regular
agencies with lots of experts checked
through all that data and decided there
was enough evidence to say that these
are effective so when a tube of adling
says it'll treat acne then it's going to
do that or at least the chance of it
doing that is going to be higher there
are other factors that can affect
whether or not it will work for you
specifically but the chances are As Good
As It Gets there's also a lot more
independent research on drugs from lots
of different research groups and less on
Cosmetics for reasons check out my
previous video for that but the
conclusion is it doesn't mean that
cosmetic retinoids don't work we just
have to do a lot more educated guesswork
and that's going to be in my next
retinoid video plus I mean they gatekeep
the stuff it's so powerful they make you
jump through hoops to get it it just
gives off a lot more like power
Vibes a less obvious but really really
important upside is that the final
formula of a drug is also tested for
Effectiveness now a lot of you are
probably thinking about the percentage
and you're correct but if you watched
some of my other videos before you'll
know it goes a lot further than just
that you can't just dump 05% Treon into
some random moisturizer and expect it to
work as well as this guy basically if
you have a good drug base it needs to
convince that active ingredient to leave
the product that you've just applied on
your skin go into your skin and go deep
enough to reach the rid receptors some
ingredients will go into skin more
easily because of their properties so
they might be a bit smaller or they
might have just the right balance of oil
and water solubility but other
ingredient need a bit more convincing
from that formula the cool thing about
drugs is that this formula here is
pretty much the same one that worked in
the scientific studies and I think all
this control and regulation over drug
formulas is where one of the biggest
myths in skincare comes from I see this
from influencers and dermatologists and
scientists and pharmacists all the time
it's the idea that percentage is
everything that matters about skincare a
lot of people fall into this trap and
it's especially people who are used to
giving out actual medications like
doctors and Pharmacists and that's
because for drugs you can usually assume
that if the percentage of the active
ingredient is the same then the generic
is going to work the same as the brand
name product but the only reason you can
assume this is actually because of this
regulation in the background Regulators
make Brands demonstrate that their
generic drug formula doesn't just have
the same percentage of active but that
it actually works the same on skin this
is something called bio equivalence and
there's a whole bunch of studies that
generic drug makers need to run to show
that their product is bio equivalent
equivalent on the skin to the brand name
one if it doesn't work the same and they
still want to sell it then they have to
go through a whole separate much more
complex drug approval process so when it
comes to drugs all this hard work is
done by regulators and manufacturers in
the background so you usually just need
to check that you've got the same active
ingredient the same percentage and the
same form but all of this regulatory
gatekeeping just doesn't really happen
with cosmetic skincare you might have a
badly formulated 1% rational that just
like sits on top of your skin and then
you might have a really well formulated
0.2% rational that actually gets more of
that rational down through your skin
into the receptors but if you're only
looking at the percentage then you would
end up picking the less effective
product there's also better stability
regulation for drugs drugs and cosmetics
are both usually tested for standard
stability unless there something that's
gone really wrong so this is stuff like
is it going lumpy or moldy too quickly
but for drug Ros the manufacturers
actually need to make sure the active
ingredient lasts in their specific
formula and in that specific packaging
so if you follow the storage directions
on the packaging and you should always
read them and I totally didn't read them
for the first time when I Was preparing
for this video it should stay pretty
close to 005 or .1% until the expiry
date but most of the time this doesn't
happen for Cosmetics which is a problem
because retinoids are pretty unstable
they just fall apart all the time now
some cosmetic brands do put in extra
effort to make sure that their retinoid
products are stable and I will talk
about those in my next cosmetic retinoid
video but the thing is they don't have
to it's perfectly legal for a brand to
just dump 1% rol into a random cream and
then just sell that and it might be
completely decomposed by the time it
gets to you and it's both legal and
actually pretty common there's this
research group that tested a whole bunch
of renoid products and a lot of the
retinoids in these were half gone 6
months after opening them and product
quality quality in general is just
better for drug products there's just
more of a guarantee that they contain
what they say they contain now this is
also legally required for Cosmetics they
should also have an accurate ingredients
list but things slip through the cracks
and they slip through less for drugs
there's more controls over how drugs are
manufactured drug Labs have to be
certified for good manufacturing
practice I know that's kind of sounds
like I'm talking about like backyard
drug Labs but I'm not I'm talking about
actual drug manufacturers so there are a
whole bunch of examples of mix that's
happened with Cosmetics for example the
inky list they got into trouble for
having 3.4% salicylic acid in their 2%
cleanser Which is higher than the legal
limit in the EU now this might seem like
it's some sort of bargain because you're
getting more of your active but I don't
think it was actually intentional
because it was like above the legal
limit it was illegal so it does kind of
make you wonder if they're messing that
up what else are they messing up the FDA
did a study in 2009 and they tested the
retinoids in 29 metics and 1th of them
had the wrong renoid or they had the
wrong concentration the research group
from earlier they also tested a whole
bunch of freshly open retinoid products
and almost all of the ones that had a
percentage on the label had a different
percentage of retinoid inside and a
bunch of them also just had the wrong
retinoid inside and again this does
happen with drug products too but there
are just a lot more safeguards in place
so all of this just makes it sound like
drug retinoids are amazing and they are
to an extent but there also some
downsides that aren't really as obvious
until you've been deep in both the drug
and the Cosmetic worlds and you've
thought about this for way way too long
the biggest Pro in my opinion is that
there is just so much more flexibility
when it comes to cosmetic formulas which
is like the flip side of all this strict
drug regulation once a drug formula gets
approved the brand can't really change
it very much without going through a new
super expensive drug approval process
and again it isn't just about percentage
or even what other moisturizing Act I
they have inside the formula so for
example Al tro is .5% Treon inside a
lotion base and that base also has
sodium hyaluronate don't know why that
word is so hard to say collagen and
glycerin and that ends up being less
irritating the manufacturer was already
making 0.5% tranon in a gel base with
the same moisturizing ingredients so to
get this new lotion base approved they
had to do two 12we clinical trials that
had over 1,600 people that is is a lot
of money according to the average in the
study this would have been tens of
millions also yes that is hyaluronic
acid in the formula can we please stop
fearmongering about how bad it is in
skincare yes it can make some
ingredients penetrate more because it is
hydrating and that can lead to
irritation but there is also evidence
that some sizes will work as an
anti-aging active we don't give other
anti-aging actors a hard time for being
irritating sometimes and drug companies
are intentionally putting it in formulas
that the betting millions of dollars on
to be less irritating anyway that is
around for a different video as you've
probably worked out the big reason we
want flexibility in formulas is
irritation it is a huge issue it's the
main reason people drop out of clinical
trials for retinoids and why people just
stop using them there are lots of hacks
for making them less irritating I did a
video on this a while back but almost
everyone who uses the stronger retinoids
will end up applying a bit too much at
some point and you end up like a red
itchy peeling mess and it always happens
right when you don't want to have that
happening like today when I was putting
on makeup and there's a whole bunch of
evidence that you can change the
irritation by changing the formula a lot
of these newer drug retinoid
formulations have these sorts of
features but they are in tons of
cosmetic products but most of the time
when you have a drug formula it is super
basic and there's another bonus in this
whole vein of irritation and messing up
your application anecdotally there is
just a lot more leeway if you apply too
much of a cosmetic renoid you you aren't
just slapped with regret with all this
like peeling and irritation and redness
like you are for drug retinoids and this
might actually be because of how kmetic
retinoids convert in skin most of them
need to turn into tranon to work
properly and a lot of people see this
purely as a downside it means that they
do tend to be weaker and less likely to
work but it might actually help them be
essentially self-limiting and time
relase versions of tracho these are the
steps for most cosmetic retinoids
turning into tanol these first two steps
are reversible so this might look
familiar if you know a bit about
equilibrium and buffers in chemistry in
theory if you apply too much of any of
these top ones it can kind of overflow
and turn into the other things and not
tranon they might just turn into tranon
a bit later but if you apply too much
tranon there's no pathway that goes back
to the less potent versions because that
is not a reversible process so there are
just less systems in place for buffering
any excess overflow and it ends up being
a lot less forgiving there's also
availability most of the time it's just
a lot easier to get cosmetic products
for most of these drug retinoid you need
to go to a doctor and have them decide
if you should get a script there's also
a really limited number of drug formulas
in some countries you can't get all of
the retinoids easily like Tartine is
really hard to get in Australia drug
products also get discontinued all the
time without having a good replacement
and it's a lot easier to buy cosmetic
products from legit retailers overseas
so drug versus cosmetic renoid which one
should you go for I'm going to go
through some of the very general things
you might want to think about obviously
I am a chemist not a medical doctor and
I don't know the specifics of your
situation if you're not sure you should
really book a conert with a cosmetic
dermatologist first off strength and
tolerance drug retinoids are generally
stronger and most of them aren't really
formulated to reduce irritation so you
do need to use them really carefully at
the start and even then most people are
going to end up having some irritation
so think about can your skin handle
retinoids this isn't the same for other
irritating ingredients so for example my
skin is really good at tolerating
chemical peels so I thought I would be
fine just slapping on rol I was not fine
my skin just kind of leapt off my face
so if you haven't used retinoids before
cosmetic ones are probably a better
starting point there are also some
genetics involved in retinoid irritation
so if your relatives have used them
before that might give you an indication
some Studies have also found that East
Asian skin is less tolerant if your skin
is sensitive in general a big part of
retinoid irritation is to do with
barrier disruption so if your barrier
isn't really happy to begin with then
you probably want to take a slow maybe
start with a cosmetic retinoid
availability and price this depends on
where you are so if you have generic
drug retinoids that can end up cheaper
but that might also depend on pack size
obviously you also need to factor in the
cost of the doctor's appointment if
you're going for the prescription ones
and which doctors can actually prescribe
retinoids in your region you can buy
prescription retinoids from overseas
pharmacies and some of them don't really
check if you have a script but I am
really not a big fan of this option A
lot of the time you don't end up really
covered by either country's regulations
so a lot of those advantages of drug
retinoids are gone like guaranteed
formula efficacy stability and that
quality control all right we need to
talk about compounded drug retinoids and
this is where you have a specially
trained pharmacist they mix up a custom
formulation from a doctor so for example
something like this with trone AIC acid
and niacinamide it's what a lot of those
Derm custom skincare companies are doing
like apostrophe curology hers dermatica
and this isn't like a criticism of any
of them specifically but it's just a
limitation of this whole system in
general it might kind of seem like
you're getting the Best of Both Worlds
you're getting drug and cosmetic you're
getting a custom formula which has those
drug actives you want at effective
concentrations but if you think about
all of these pros and cons that we've
just been through you actually lose a
lot of the advantages of both drugs and
cosmetics ICS on the upside you do get
the more effective drug retinoid as the
active but because it's a custom formula
the formula efficacy and stability
aren't being tested compounding
pharmacists are going to look for
obvious clashes and then mix the
ingredients into some sort of generic
base but that is it so the efficacy and
stability is almost definitely going to
end up worse than an off-the-shelf drug
retinoid maybe even some cosmetic
skincare products that have been
properly tested the formula flexibility
also isn't that great you do get to
combine actives but the compounding
pharmacy might not necessarily have a
huge range and it will depend on what
your doctor gives you you usually also
don't get much choice for the base it's
a base that's been optimized to work
well for a bunch of different actives
it's not really optimized to be for
Treon or necessarily nice to use there
are some Tel companies that have nicer
bases they use but it's still not really
a guarantee in theory they could be
optimizing their formulas and making
them deliver better and be more stable
because they do tend to prescribe a
whole bunch of formulas that are really
similar but as far as I can tell none of
them are actually doing that all of them
seem to have some reviews saying that
their brand new product has like
scratchy crystals in it and that is a
pretty basic stability issue that
shouldn't be there for Cosmetics their
expiry dates are usually the default
compounding 3 to 4 months versus 6 to 12
months for an off-the-shelf drug
retinoid also 6 to 12 months or even
longer for the good cosmetic retinoids
so I actually think a better option for
most people would just be layering and
off-the-shelf Drug with a cosmetic
skincare product that has the other
actors you want it's a lot less
convenient for application you do have
to squeeze out two products instead of
one but you can get good stability for
the separate products and there is
efficacy testing and stability testing
for the drug and maybe also the Cosmetic
product the efficacy might drop a bit if
you mix them but it is still better than
no testing and you can wait a bit in
between layers to try to give it the
best chance possible but it does really
depend on your situation for some people
it might end up better because you do
get that doctor's appointment wrapped up
in there but I think just the formula
part is just super overrated so that is
drug versus cosmetic retinoids we did it
Joe remember you don't have to choose
just one or the other I personally will
use both depending on how my skin is
feeling now before you start slapping a
retinoid on your face you'll want to
know how you're meant to introduce them
without your skin falling off I have a
video on that and my ebook tells you how
to get a skincare routine going next
I'll be talking about all the different
drug retinoids then I'll go into all the
Cosmetic retinoids in the meantime you
can check out my deep dive on vitamin C
or just my skincare science playlist
special shout out to Sam one of my ex-
students who is a pharmacist and
Pharmacy instructor for helping me out
on the compounding stuff and Ruby for
giving me feedback you can check out the
written version of this on my website
which has a lot more info and references